what makes a great photograph great  maybe it's when it takes us back to a  moment in history that we've read about  or heard about and reminds us of just  how real it all was maybe it's when you  get to witness someone making a choice a  choice to stand up a choice to believe  in something to be brave to do what  others are afraid to do sometimes it's  seen innocence in the middle of turmoil  in the middle of something too big to  understand  or just a moment of silence sometimes  the cameras right in the thick of it and  you feel like you couldn't have gotten  any closer  and sometimes the camera turns away from  the spectacle we can still see  everything that's important and gesture  or in a face sometimes the subject of  the photograph isn't in the picture at  all days have gone by years but it's  still there  often the theme is something simple  something we can all relate to loss  relief joy they're pictures of us and  often they don't need any words at all